i heard i don't know if this is true but
i was told by one of my producers is a
rumor that you love dogs so much that
you're such a fanatic for for dogs that
you even occasionally eat a dog biscuit
true or false on my fetch dog blob this
i blog i said blob
um
i used to eat dog biscuits all the time
when i was little didn't you i mean i
can't believe no i never ate a dog
biscuit
we weren't a wealthy family but you need
a dog biscuit oh someone else here just
put up there's a woman on the front row
was like me too
really you ate you occasionally now when
was the last time you ate a dog biscuit
not for a while
probably not since i was an adult i have
whatever that is a milk bone oh my god
congress get right here
now you don't have to do this you don't
have to you are glenn close
very respected
actor
but you've clearly come on the wrong
show
interested it all doesn't look good from
here absolutely what are you talking
about
right
oh my god
wow
[Applause]
you're not gonna spit it out are you
no i'm not gonna spit it out you have to
swallow it
[Laughter]
i cannot wait to go to commercial
is ridiculous to say with a mouthful of
dog biscuit
but your new show damages
there's no transition possible here
there's darkness get flying out of my
mouth
your new show damages
[Music]
one of the most critically acclaimed
shows on television right now
[Applause]
that's right we have a clip here from
damages
would you like to set up this clip
do you think it's possible well as we
eat dog business it's a long time to
chew and swallow it certainly does
um
maybe we should look at the ingredient
no i really don't think we should
that's the worst advice i've had in a
long time that doesn't give you anal
leakage
oh my god
sorry when close
never mind they didn't hear that yeah
but i repeat it